[موسيقى]
العوام الثلاثون يا استاذ مشاري هي سرطان
مع السودانيين على مدى عقود طويله
للاسف الشديد يعني يعني هؤلاء الاسلاميه
السياسيه عاده اي دوله يعني ينشا فيها
يعمل انقسامات شاهدنا هذا في غزه فيها
افغانستان في الصومال في السودان لانه هو
كان متحكم تماما انقذ من الدوله قسمين
يعني انفصال الجنوب وهذه جريمه كبيره بكل
المقاييس هذه الجريمه من جريمه اكثر
بتلعب الدوله
الوزارات كلها الى جيوبه خاصه
[موسيقى]
هل استسلم اصحاب الثلاثين عاما الان
يستثمرون هذه الاموال من خلال دول خارجيه
في السوشيال ميديا يعني لما قدم حمدوق
وصار رئيس الوزراء وسوا انسان نزيه وانسان
موظف اموي معروف مقدم خدمات عميقه جدا في
سهل العاج في تطور الديمقراطي لما جاء
حمدوه
هم عبر الكتروني وعنده جدا
جدا في انطباعات الاخرين
عامه الناس